welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gayle King with Tony to copal and
Anthony Mason who apparently likes
puppets the New England agents are
denying a new allegation of spying this
time on the team they're playing on
Sunday a Patriots crew was caught
filming the Cincinnati Bengals sideline
last weekend now you may remember
Spygate back in 2007 to 2007 is what
she's trying to say when the Patriots
were punished for taping opponents
vladimir duthiers our streaming network
cbsn is here with more on this story
Vlad good morning to you what is
happening here yeah gail the bengals
reportedly think the Patriots tried
stealing signals but the Patriots accept
some responsibility and call the entire
thing a misunderstanding the NFL is
investigating to determine whether it
was something more
[Applause]
as the Cleveland Browns claimed victory
over the Cincinnati Bengals Sunday
suspicions brewed in the press box above
a Bengals official says he saw a
Patriots employee in the room
inappropriately filming the sidelines
during the game and notified the NFL I'm
aware that there was an incident but I
know he is investigating action so no
comment
the Patriots say they were filming for
an upcoming episode of their behind the
scenes web series do your job wait
following a patriot Scout at the game in
a statement Monday the team says they
got the Browns permission the shoot but
not the Bengals or the NFL's coach Bill
Belichick denied any knowledge of it we
have absolutely nothing to do with
anything that they produce direct or
shoot in 2007 the Patriots were fined
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
after an investigation found they spied
on the New York Jets coaches during a
game then in 2016 quarterback Tom Brady
was suspended for four games over an
accusation that he was involved in
deflating footballs during the 2015 AFC
Championship game to make them easier to
grip you know I didn't alter the ball in
any way once I approved the ball like I
said that's the ball that I expect out
there on the field I've always played
within the rules I would never do
anything to break the rules it's worth
noting the Bengals have only won a
single game this season the Patriots
lead the AFC East with ten wins the NFL
has confiscated the tape as part of its
investigation and they're not commenting
on the matter very interesting I mean
look a lot of people are like look again
yes exactly how many times which makes
you think why would they do it again
since they since it's already happened
once why would they do it although I
didn't ask for permission you know yeah
also 250k not a lot of money though at
the pocket oh well the investigation
continues I'm not drawing judgment all
right thanks